Quand j'ai fait Bridges of Madison
County, j'avais 45 ans et il y a eu une grosse
bagarre avec le studio parce qu'ils disaient que
j'étais trop vieux et que mon co-star Clint avait
65 ans.
[Musique]
tu es là où tu as grandi et j'ai grandi
à New York.  Jersey, dans une ville de 5 000 habitants.
J'adore chanter, mais je veux dire, c'est une
grande joie.
J'ai consacré 7 ans, 7 de mes plus
belles années, à devenir pom-pom girl
pour le football, le basket-ball et la lutte.
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Je ne le fais pas.  Je ne les considère pas comme des femmes fortes, des
femmes faibles, des femmes hésitantes, des
femmes d'opposition. J'aime les
femmes difficiles ou du moins celles qui sont
difficiles à comprendre.
[Musique]
bien, avez-vous ses femmes qui
essaient de réussir à Hollywood
oh je suppose oh je  je ne sais pas, ne vous inquiétez pas
de votre chemin, souciez-vous de votre beauté intérieure
[Musique] il n'y
a pas de Musée national de l'histoire des femmes
mais il y a beaucoup d'histoire
qui n'est pas écrite sur les
contributions des femmes dans notre pays
et dans le monde ou  pendant de nombreux
siècles, l'histoire ne s'est pas intéressée à
nous et pourtant et notre histoire est invisible
la chose la plus dangereuse que tu puisses mettre n'importe quel
obstacle devant moi et je sauterai
par-dessus mais quand je perds courage, tu perds
tout et donc tu prends ta force
de tes amis, de cette personne
dans ta vie qui a dit que tu étais
capable  je n'en ai absolument besoin que d'une
[Musique]
Je suis très attaché à l'égalité et à
l'inclusion des personnes de tous genres, races,
ethnies, religions, il devrait y avoir
une inclusion et ce jury est la preuve qu'au
moins les femmes sont incluses et dominent en fait
ce jury, le monde devrait être
représenté  moitié-moitié c'est ce que je
pense,
ce n'est pas du tout binaire, mais je
pense que vous savez que l'inclusion est le
nom du jour ouais et c'est bien d'être
Boss
[Musique]
Je suis le plus surfait et le plus
exagéré  décorée
et actuellement je suis l'
actrice la plus réprimandée si nous vivons
ce moment précaire si son
instinct catastrophique de riposte
ne nous conduit pas à un hiver nucléaire, nous
aurons beaucoup à remercier ce président
car il nous aura réveillé sur
la façon dont  la liberté fragile est vraiment
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aux États-Unis, il y avait un
présentateur de nouvelles qui avait un bouton sous son
bureau qui verrouillait la porte quand et
vous savez, ses jeunes stagiaires
entraient, je veux dire  ce sont des
abus au-delà de ce qu'on peut imaginer honnêtement et je
ne devrais pas être sur le lieu de travail, tout le monde
mérite un lieu de travail respectueux
et sûr
[Musique] [
Musique]
vous ne pouvez jamais rien prendre pour acquis
ou supposer que quoi que ce soit, travaillez aussi dur que
possible  faites tout ce que vous pouvez et croisez
les doigts en espérant que
[Musique]
vous